[Music]
[Music]
hello
i'm alexander rose the executive
director here at long now
i'm joined today from british columbia
by our speaker dr suzanne simard
suzanne has developed revolutionary new
techniques for discovering the way trees
even between species
are able to articulate their needs
within the forest
welcome dr suzanne smart
hello it's an honor for me to be here my
name is dr
suzanne simard i'm a professor at the
university of british columbia
and a researcher i'm here to talk to you
today about mother trees
and how i discovered their importance in
forests
and how they contribute sort of to what
i'm calling the wisdom of the forest
so before i start i just want to
acknowledge first of all that i am
giving this talk and most of my research
is on the unseated territory of a number
of first nations
here in canada i'm actually in nelson
british columbia right now on the
unseated territory of the tanaha
the tsarnaex and the okanagan nations
when i do my work
in vancouver which is where i teach
and where my university is that is the
territories
of the musqueam the slava tooth and the
squamish
first nations in british columbia there
are
almost all of the territories unseated
territory so it's very important for us
to acknowledge the land on which we live
i am actually a settler i come from a
settler family
but i work with first nations and their
wisdom has contributed enormously to
what i'm about to tell you today and
also to all of our livelihoods
and we'll be in our future and i think
that you'll you'll see that as i go
through my talk
so i'm going to give you some context
like what drove me to do the research i
did
my own background as a child of british
columbia and i grew up here
in a logging family a horse logging
family i grew up in
forests that were are called inland
rainforests
these are amazing forests they're what
you would call biodiversity hot spots in
the world
they're also hot spots for carbon
storage and they're also the source of
our clean air and our clean water
here in british columbia and it flows
all the way down through through north
america
so the value of these forests is beyond
anything we imagined even 50 years ago
now we
understand you know how crucial they are
in our global
world and the changing global world so i
grew up in these places
and my research really started from when
i was a child and it's just move forward
and trying to understand
how they work and how we can how we we
can honor them
and their wisdom to help us to live in a
happy and healthy environment when my
family came to north america they eked
out a living and they did it through
selective harvesting
so that what that means is that they
would take out you know certain species
and certain sizes of trees
and then left the forest to regenerate
itself there was no planting back then
it was just that the the logging was
such a light touch
that the trees were able to reseed into
these small gaps created
by the harvesting and then become a
forest
it just seemed like that my grandfather
and my uncles were all part of the
forest and the
forest grew up around them and we grew
up around the forest
and so that's how i got to know it so
everything was very labor intensive and
very
very very slow and that's so important
because
as they did this work it was a very
light touch on the landscape it was very
much
you know you just take what you need and
then leave the rest
this is a photo here of my grandfather
and my uncle's on what's called
it's a log boom in what was called this
kukum chuck narrows on the shushwa
river they were regularly crushed in
these logging
adventures and they would have to break
up these log jams with dynamite they
would lose their hands their fingers
almost all of my uncles and grandfathers
and great uncles
had missing fingers it was pretty
exciting way to grow up
and so i actually followed in my
grandfather's footsteps when i was
uh in my teens you know if girls weren't
actually allowed to go into forestry
we were um you know we were supposed to
go into nursing or
education or something and so um it was
kind of an unusual pathway for me and i
was really lucky
at the time that that ubc where where i
went to university
had just opened its doors to girls and i
was able to start out
doing forestry and this is me when i'm
in my early 20s working for a logging
company
so that would have been in the late 70s
and then the early 80s
the whole logging practices had shifted
and they shifted from this
small scale horse logging family
operations to
big indus industrial clear cutting and
so that's how i started out my careers
is looking at big industrial clear
cutting which was so different than what
how i had grown up
and right now in british columbia we're
really grappling with
the fact that we only have three percent
of our iconic old growth rainforest
left going back to my own neighborhood
my own where i grew up this is the shop
river where my
grandparents the smart family had
homesteaded but it had become a place of
clear cutting as well
and that you can imagine the impact that
would have had
and the changes are cumulative and we're
seeing that signature on the landscape
now
this is an is actually a picture taken
about 15 years ago
of what our landscape looks like so i
grew up in a landscape of old growth
forests
british columbia western canada is and i
would say of the west
of of the united states as well has
shifted from a landscape of old growth
forests
to a landscape of clear cuts with only
small
pockets of old growth forests that are
left there are huge
implications for that we've converted
these old growth forests to plantations
and this is what these plantations look
like clear cutting means taking away
all of the trees and then they're
replanted to one or two species
in this case douglas fir this is a
monoculture meaning one species
and then they're cultivated or weeded
and tended to get rid of all the other
or as many of the other plants as
possible to favor
these trees with the idea being that if
you get rid of the native plants
then all those resources will be
available to grow big fat trees
of course as i moved along in my career
i eventually became a researcher and one
of my jobs was to figure out how to grow
plantations
and then if there's something wrong with
them what the heck is wrong with them
and what can we do about it
and as i started working on this at the
time in the early 90s i was working in
the
ministry of forests the government and
that was also when the mountain pine
beetles started coming through
and we started noticing that in these
plantations so this is a plantation of
logical pine
in a sub boreal spruce forest where the
beetle has specifically attacked and
killed those planted lodgepole pines
and why is that the case well the
problem here is it was planted one
species
in a sea of a multi-species forest
and so it was like a had a target on its
back for the beetle it was exactly what
the beetle wanted was a simplified
forest
that had been weeded to grow bigger
faster lodgepole pines that were the
host of the beetle
and i've done many studies since then to
show that we have like about 50
different damaging agents in these kinds
of forests now
that are basically chewing their way
through and as
climate is warming up we found that it's
getting worse and worse
i started to do some research on what's
going on in the soil
so there are big pathogens that were
killing forests and
a lot of those big pathogens attacked
big roots of old trees
but we were also noticing trees dying in
plantations of course
and so i went back to school to try to
figure out what had we done
to create this imbalance in the soil and
among these fungi
that would make the forest more
vulnerable and so
i was looking at a smaller subset of
fungi mycorrhizaes
and these fungi they're mutualists that
means that they help the trees grow they
don't decay them they don't infect them
or they don't cause them to decline and
so i started studying this in our
forests
the first work that i i did on looking
at connections and communications
between trees is i started with a
complex system
a simpler system would be to work with
one species but i was working with two
because i was interested in
how we were manipulating these species
and i worked with three
actually i worked with douglas fir paper
birch and western red cedar
which are all native species in my
forest and
douglas fir is the one that foresters
want because it
brings top dollar paper birch is
considered a weed
and so it's actively managed against
it's actually
weeded out of forest using herbicides
and anything we can get our hands on to
get rid of that pesky plant because it's
supposedly stealing from douglas fur
resources light water and so on
and then the third species was western
red cedar which
of course is a really valuable species
for lots of reasons but into foresters
it wasn't at that time it was considered
a pesky species even though our first
nations consider it they actually call
it the tree of life
because of all of the benefits it
provides to ecosystems as well as
people but but in the forestry world at
the time it was considered a weed as
well
but i used the three species to look at
communication and connection because
they all had different roles in the
ecosystem and through many years of
studies with my students and
and others determined that throughout
our forests
throughout the world that trees depend
on these mycorrhizaes
and that these plants actually are
networked together into a single unit by
these fungi that
all of the trees all over the world with
their mycorrhizal fungi
actually are connected together we are
also able to detect
defense enzymes and how when a tree is
injured like a mother tree gets attacked
by the mountain pine beetle
what kind of messages is that tree
sending to to neighboring seedlings and
so we're able to actually detect these
enzymes that end up
uh in the neighboring plants and how the
the
rna and the dna is upregulated in
response to
those enzymes so that these neighboring
plants can actually upregulate and
produce their own defense enzymes as
well at the time there was a lot of
skepticism about this
i published a paper in nature that went
into what these connections meant
to the forest and there was a lot of
skepticism that
these things didn't actually exist in
nature or they weren't important
these fungi you can't see them with the
naked eye
even the microscope even though you can
see them on the root tips
you can't actually see how these threads
move or travel through the soil
and so eventually we got molecular tools
where we could actually
you know identify fungi based based on
their dna sequences
and we went into a forest of douglas fir
a simple forest
you know it was a native or primary
forest that means that it had never been
logged
and so we went in and we wanted to map
the fungi and the trees
in this map the circles in the fred gear
represent trees
and the bigger the circle the bigger the
tree and the darker the circle the older
the tree
so the oldest trees in this little
forest
are about 300 years old and the youngest
trees which are the little yellow
circles in the middle are about 10 years
old
and so it's a multi-age forest based on
this figure
so we call those uneven age forests and
you can see
there's about 60 trees in this forest um
and then the lines that are linking
these different circles or these trees
together are the fungal jennas or the
individual fungi
of two species that we were tracking and
these two
sister species were basically linking
all of the trees
together and the biggest oldest tree
which is up in the upper right hand
corner of the figure
was actually of the 60 trees was linked
to 47
other trees and so it turned out that
every tree was linked to every other
tree through a series of hop skips and
jumps
and so this map alone just completely
transformed how people were viewing
forests at the time which was that
trees were individuals that that
competed for resources and that
competition isn't the only thing that's
happening in these forests that there's
a lot of collaboration going on
in that collaboration one of the vectors
for that collaboration are these
mycorrhizal linkages
the one thing to notice is that these
little trees these little yellow
seedlings that you can see here these 10
year olds
when the seed falls from the old trees
these old
big old 300 year old trees the seed
falls to the forest floor
it germinates you know as soon as it
germinates it
the seed will send a hypocotyl down into
the soil which starts sending signals
to the other roots and fungi and
critters bacteria in the soil there's a
huge communication going on
a chemical communication basically they
just link into the network of the old
trees
they become part of this big woven quilt
those seedlings suddenly have a huge
resource available to them
they've got the resources of their
elders they have they also just by
having the mycorrhizaes they're able to
also
access all the nutrients and water in
the soil that these big old trees are
able to access as well
you know it's like inheriting a large
bank account as soon as you're born
so the other thing that happens they get
mycorrhizal but they also start
receiving
subsidies from these old trees if they
didn't have these subsidies they would
die
they wouldn't make it in the understory
of these old trees it's too shady it's
too dark
they can't photosynthesize enough on
their own and so it's a very dynamic
environment throughout the life of these
trees and
archived in their tree rings then is
that history
they tell a story of the stresses and
the riches that come along to a tree
throughout their lifetime eventually
these young seedlings themselves grow up
to become mother trees themselves
and then they you know have tons of
resources they can send to their own
seedlings
well can these old trees do they nurture
all the
seedlings can it be a different species
it's like a community right with all the
different people in that community like
my little town of nelson with all the
different people
you know that have all their professions
and we interact in that very fluid way
it's the same thing in the forest with
all their specialties well it turns out
that these old trees can recognize which
ones are their own seedlings
they have kin recognition and that
they're able to
adjust where they're sending carbon
based on the identity of their kin
and so in the process of doing that they
actually favor their own genes they
favor their kin
and that carries the line forward in a
real in a forest if we were to look at
every species of fungi in every network
there would be
hundreds and the linkages would be so
dense and so numerous you wouldn't even
be able to
to see that it would be just opaque
so what do we do about this other than
protesting and chaining ourselves to
trees
yes by all means let's do that but
there's we also need to figure out ways
where we can emulate some of these more
careful management practices
based on being on the land and listening
and trying to protect
those wonderful resources and all that
at the same time as protecting
you know biodiversity carbon storage and
all
while climate is changing and making it
harder and harder and harder to do that
so how can we help these forests so i
started a project
about five years ago to try to address
some of these things
called the mother tree project the basic
idea is taking that basic research
on tree communication and connection and
applying it in forestry practices
so that we can actually look after the
basic things that we need in order to
have a life on this planet which it
means protecting our forests
protecting the carbon stocks that are in
those forests the biodiversity that's in
them
and so we wanted to retain mother trees
in different amounts and configurations
with the idea that we knew that they
were essential to regeneration and
essential to protecting
all the other creatures in the forest
and we also wanted to look at genetic
gradients because we knew
already that the rate of climate change
is so fast the velocity is so high
that trees cannot migrate as quickly as
we need them to in order to retain
forests on our earth to retain forested
landscape
we're going to have to help them migrate
we're going to help species
and genotypes move because we've made it
too fast for them to do it on their own
i'm going to show you some of our early
results on this we focused on one
particular forest type
douglas fir because it's got this big
broad range across british columbia
so these are undergraduate and graduate
students and they are the lifeblood of
this
of this project it's a hundred year
project i'm going to be gone well before
it even reached
the forest reaches a teenage year and so
they're going to be the ones that are
carrying this into the future
this is the biggest experiment i've ever
designed it's probably one of the
biggest climate experiments in forests
in north america so we have actually a
total of 27
forests that have been treated in
different ways where we
retain mother trees in different
configurations and compare them to an
uncut primary forest so a native forest
and then we've taken that native forest
and cut out different patches of trees
leaving these different mother trees in
different amounts and configurations so
the 60
means that we we cut out gaps of trees
and left 60 percent of the mother trees
and thinned them from below
to try to boost their vigor and then
with the next one this 30
is we created larger gaps in the forest
and left patches of 30
so just smaller patches this 10 percent
is what's known as a seed tree method
it's a very common forest harvesting
method
across europe and north america where
you leave individual trees
the problem with it is that what we have
found
across british columbia anyway is that
about a third of those trees are dead
within five years
and that's part of the reasoning behind
having these 30 and 60
patches as well to protect the mother
trees from dying
from blowing over or just dying from
stress or shock
from losing its neighbors and its family
we wanted to track the biodiversity so
we measured
everything like the lichens and the
mosses the plants the trees
the small mammals the large mammals we'd
like to look at the birds
um and and also whereas all the carbon
in those
ecosystems we measured you know every
stick every plant every tree
we dug our soils down to a meter and
collected soil from all those different
depths
we took them back to the lab and we
measured all the nitrogen and carbon in
those samples
and we were able to actually reconstruct
the carbon budget for our forest
so all of our 27 sites then had to be
harvested by all of our partners
which was a huge undertaking and then me
and my students went out and planted all
of our special seedlings in these
forests
and now we're going back and evaluating
how they look what the biodiversity is
so one of the things along our big
climate gradient is that we know
naturally that tree species richness or
how many trees
are there varies and sure enough that's
reflected in our data
where and this also happens worldwide
that when you have
replete climates with with very good
climatic conditions there's more tree
species
and then as it gets drier and drier and
more
harsh you have fewer tree species and
tree species richness is
correlated with carbon but tree species
richness isn't the only thing
when we look at the full suite of
species and i'm just talking about
plants right now
all through from the top of the trees
down into the soil
this is the carbon pools in our forest
and so we have
here's our dry forest at the left-hand
side of our curve and our wettest
climatic region on the far right part of
the curve
the brown part of the figure is what's
below ground
and the green part is the carbon above
ground so
here's an amazing thing is that when
you're walking through the forest
everything that you see all the trees
the plants what's on the ground
that's only half of the carbon the other
half is hidden away from site below
ground
and that is where our really stable
carbon pools are those are so precious
to us
with climate change we can take off the
above ground and harvest it and
turn it into toilet paper but we need to
make sure that that below ground pool is
really stable and safe in the ground so
that we don't double the problem
if you just look at the raw data what
this figure here is showing is that as
you increase the
number of tree species in plantations
and i'm thinking plantations here
because keep in mind we only plant one
or two species because we're very
simplistic
with our management we're always keeping
that carbon pool
low if we do that right the reason for
that is as you add more species in the
ecosystem
they start occupying different niche
spaces above ground and below ground so
above ground if you look at this
nice picture on the diagram you can see
all these different tree species with
their have
occupied different layers of the canopy
some of them are photo
synthesizing in the upper canopy some
are shade tolerant and doing it in the
lower canopy
but they're occupying or they're
accessing or acquiring
all those sun rays that are coming in
there and converting them into
photosynthate and it's photosynthate
that
drives the whole below ground processes
all the nutrient cycle the carbon cycle
the water cycle and what's going on
below ground too as you add more species
of trees is they too
occupy different niches in the soil and
if you start taking species away you
start
basically truncating the ability of the
ecosystem to acquire resources and be
productive
and so by simplifying our ecosystems and
it doesn't matter if it's a forest
or a grassland or a cropland that when
we simplify to a few species we actually
lose these niches or we don't occupy
them and we lower the productivity of
our
of our plant communities so there's a
lesson here for
management okay now i'm just going to
talk about
one last little piece here and that is
what is the effect of leaving these old
mother trees
on regeneration and this is just a
subset of our regeneration data so this
is really talking about the ability
of the forest to recover right it's
resilience
this is looking at total density of up
to three years post-harvesting
and you can see that you know in forests
where we're intact or where we left a
lot of the mother trees
there's a lot of regen right they're
recovering really
fast as we clear-cut we get less and
less and less and less
you well that seems obvious because
there's fewer trees there but there's
just fewer seed around and they're more
at risk of dying from frost
and drought and even if they do get
established the other thing here is that
the richness of species so that is
the number of species coming back also
is greater when we leave more over story
covers leaving these mother trees is not
just important for density is important
for
the diversity of the species coming back
along this
axis here the z-axis is our aridity
gradient or
our climate gradient and this is just
showing that in a really favorable
environments where it's wet and cool
that we get a lot of regeneration as it
gets drier which is these
orange bars in front dry hot
environments it's a lot harder
so in harsher environments either
hot and dry or cold and dry regeneration
is a lot more difficult in those
ecosystems you need
a lot more protection so i mentioned how
our species our trees cannot
keep up with the rate of climate change
the velocity of climate change
is orders of magnitude higher than what
trees can migrate at the pace that they
can migrate at
and so we have to help them we have to
move them around
and so we've done that in this project
and what we've found
first of all is that these warmer
genotypes that we as we
move them north they're actually doing
okay right
it's warmed up enough that that they're
surviving in these warmer climates that
we've created through climate change so
our ability to migrate stuff is actually
pretty darn good
the second thing i want you to notice is
in these other figures this is the
driest and hottest site
and this is the most northern site that
most northern side is the
northern limit of douglas fir
douglas fir is projected to actually
migrate all the way up to the yukon
as climate changes over the next century
it's going to move if it can
it's going to move but what this is
showing is that if they're going to need
to have
protective trees in order for them to do
that so this is our 60
retention treatment and our 100
retention
and this is the clear cut and you can
see that the clear cuts are not
the survival and the height growth is
not as great
as it is under these retention
treatments how important is this it's
hugely important
because if you fly over the north of
british columbia all we do is clear-cut
right that is all we do if you fly over
the north of
across the boreal forest all we do is
clear-cut so we're actually setting
ourselves up for
a pretty tough time if we're going to be
migrating species
this is a very compelling argument for
changing the whole thing
and we need to change it quickly because
climate is changing so fast
we need to shift away from clear cutting
in the north
to partial retention so we can migrate
species so they have their mother trees
to look after them
to help them succeed in these colder and
drier climates and therefore we can
actually
keep forests alive on the ground and
productive and healthy
and able to sequester carbon and house
biodiversity
and my final point here is that keeping
these old trees around here
also mitigates fire risk right they're
not as fire prone as young plantations
are
those young plantations full of douglas
were in lodgepole pine
it's like you could throw a match in
them and they and they just go up
because they're so
flammable but old trees they have thick
bark they have deep roots they keep the
forest moisture by bringing water up
from deep down
and they cause the risk of fire to go
down
in a big way and we've measured that in
our project
and this just shows and i'm you don't
have to understand this whole thing but
this is just like if you look on the
blue side over here this is one of our
sites
uh the wettest site and it shows that
clear cutting the risk and this is just
risk of fire is higher in our clear cuts
by about double than it is where we
retain these old trees and it's because
the old trees are less
less flammable and it's also because
there's less
slash left around after after harvesting
as well
so there's multiple benefits to having
these old mother trees
for uh storing carbon for keeping
healthy forests
for having a resilient forest in the
future so let me just go through these
concluding
remarks is that our forests are under a
lot of stress
they're stressed out from climate change
and they're stressed out from how we've
managed them over the last hundred years
and this is only going to amplify in the
future and they need
our help you know we've gotten to the
point where we can't we can't just walk
away
we've got to do something to help them
migrate and be productive moving forward
and we can do that by retaining these
old tree neighborhoods
for enhancing regeneration protecting
the new seedlings coming up
housing the biodiversity and protecting
those carbon stocks
and this is going to be especially
crucial in harsher environments where
seedlings just like our babies when we
grow
when they grow up in our little human
families they need our help right
those little seedlings we're going to
need the help of their mother trees
and so we and especially on harsher
sites where
there's there's more risks involved and
we can migrate these genotypes from from
warmer to to colder climates
as climate changes we need to do it it
can be successful
but it's going to be more successful if
we leave the old trees around
in fact we could be you know it could be
a disaster if we don't keep those old
trees around
it would be like you know creating a
like a parking lot to try to put your
kids out on it
you just don't want to do that you want
to have a nice healthy environment for
them
to be moved into and how you retain
those old trees the patterns
it's all got to be based on the land
watching the land knowing the land
seeing what's going on seeing how it's
changing that means having people on the
land
and knowing the land it means getting
out of our cities and going out and
actually being part of the management of
our forests
and finally doing experiments like what
i've done with the mother tree project
is wonderful for young people obviously
for students
they can go be part of it and feel like
their agents have changed
i can't emphasize how important that is
but also we can go look at these
experiments and we can say okay that
worked and that didn't work and that
worked before but it doesn't work now
so we can use them to calibrate
ourselves we can use them to
create models to project into the future
and validate those models and
lastly to motivate us to change because
when we
when we can see what what what's
positive and helpful
then we can we can emulate that and
build on it
so thank you very much and i hope i hope
that this presentation
was enlightening i hope that you can see
how my early work on plant communication
and saving old mother trees is important
not just in healthy forests but how
we can use this knowledge to help us
look after our forests in the future so
thank you so much
thank you so much that was fantastic and
i'd love to welcome
dr suzanne simard live onto our stream
from
columbia welcome thank you thank you for
having me
and uh some of you have already been
putting messages into
our live stream we're already getting
some great questions we'll also have
kevin kelly one of our founders here at
long now come in for some live questions
um but i'll get us started one of the
questions that i had as i was listening
to this talk is
is how old how old are these biomes in
these forests that we're
talking about is this was this the last
ice age that
that they have that they were kind of
wiped out and restarted or is it kind of
40
000 years 30 000 years 10 000 years
you know well the last ice age in canada
and that moved par part way down into
the u.s in the boreal forest in the u.s
was about
12 000 years ago um and so
you know a lot of the species have
migrated
northward following the the last ice age
um so it wasn't really that long ago
um uh yeah so that by
i guess the boreal biome um
would have developed in that period of
time but the temperate and
tropical forests to the south have been
you know not glaciated
through that time so they're much much
older for us the soils are much much
older
as well of course right well and that's
interesting so do you know if um if
tropical forests communicate in similar
ways
has that been done yeah i mean i haven't
done that work myself myself but other
people have
and so in tropical forests um there's a
certain kind of mycorrhizal fungus it's
a
you know they're different groups of
fungi and the boreal and temperate
forests are dominated by what we call
ectomycorrhizals but in the tropical
forests
um those fungi are called arbuscular
mycorrhizaes
there is only a few hundred species of
our muscular mycorrhizaes
worldwide so the tropical trees a lot of
the herbaceous plants
throughout the world from these are
muscular mycorrhizaes but because
there's so few species
that means that most of these fungi are
considered generalists host generals
that means that they can associate with
many different
species of trees and so people have
found you know people who have looked
have found that these tropical trees do
have networks as well and that they do
transmit information and carbon
um amongst trees through the networks
that's very cool and you mentioned how
some of these trees effectively have a
memory that's
encoded in their tree rings and i think
and we got a chance to talk a little bit
about
some of the other ways that that works
with some of the native cultures and
even the way that they harvested fish
can you
talk a little bit about that yeah so
you know yeah so the memory of trees is
encoded in their
in their tree rings it's also encoded in
in their the genes in their
in their seeds um but you know in terms
of you know just annual growth rings of
a
current life of a tree um you know
there's so much information
in those rings and thinking thinking of
some of the oldest trees in the world
the bristlecone pines are about 5000
years old
there are trees along the west coast um
redwoods and cedars that are
a thousand or two thousand years old so
that's a lot of history that's recorded
there
and one of the interesting things on the
west coast is that um
salmon salmon which migrate from the
ocean and spawn in the in the rivers
inland
um carry with them a heavy isotope of
nitrogen
called n15 and n15 you can think of it
as bio
accumulating in these in the salmon
because they're like top
of their food chain and that n15 that
heavy isotope
can serve or we've used scientists have
used it as a tracer to see where that
salmon
nitrogen ends up and so when salmon are
spawning
um in the rivers uh we've people have
found
that some of that n50 not some of that
salmon nitrogen
ends up in the trees so how does that
happen
well um when salmons spawn in the fall
there's bears that are preying on the
carcasses as well as wolves and
eagles and ravens and they they actually
carry it into the forest
in fact a single bear has been shown to
carry 175 fish in a single day
and they'll take it to their favorite
place
um sometimes under a big old mother tree
and with their cubs they'll eat
the flesh of this of the salmon usually
they actually they eat the brains and
the guts because that's where the most
energy
is and they'll leave the the fillets the
stuff that we like to eat
which decomposes and then the microrises
actually
pick up that salmon nitrogen along with
the n15 that's embedded in those
proteins
and it is uh carried right into the tree
rings and becomes part of the
of the tissue of the tree rings and so
we can actually
shave off those tree rings and run them
through a mass spec and say okay there's
this much salmon nitrogen in this year
was absorbed by this tree
um and so then we can reconstruct
actually salmon populations over time
and i i would add one more thing to this
story
is that the that the first nations
people um knew this
for a long long time and they actually
help cultivate or nourish the forest by
burying the guts of salmon that they
caught
at the base of trees or at the base of
salmonberries to
increase the productivity of the forest
they would also return the bones of the
salmon to the streams to increase the
mineral
content of the stream so it's better for
spawning of salmon
and also the last thing i would say is
they also have these ancient fishing
technologies
that really help to increase the salmon
populations they would throw back the
big mothers for example
um so that the big you know that they
would
lay big eggs for bigger fish in the
future and they were always
um very conscious and aware of the
variability in the salmon populations
because they vary up and down over the
years that they're on a four year cycle
and so in the years where the silent
populations were low they didn't take as
much
and they always threw back the big
mothers and then so doing kept the
salmon populations healthy
and that kept the forest healthy as well
and of course when colonization happened
that fishery those fishery technologies
were those ancient technologies were
were either outlawed or banned or or at
least
they weren't uh learned from anyway they
were ignored and so then
the the colonization of the fishery
actually has decimated salmon
populations
and we can see that in the tree rings as
well so it's yeah it's interesting
but such a miraculous story that we have
that kind of
that much history to understand both not
the just the plants world but the animal
world that surrounded it
um it's very cool and you know long now
has uh
bristle compounds on our property in
eastern sierra and
learn we've been learning with the tree
ring lab and other other researchers
um like you and r about how much we do
learn out of that history
so it's yeah amazing but i didn't know
the story about the salmon so it's
yeah yeah it's we have a great question
from uh sean from our facebook feed um
asking do the micro razia serve only as
communication medium or
are they themselves originators of
messages too are they
are they adding information into that
stream or are they just helping the
trees along
yeah no they're they're uh partners in
this whole
complex system as well and so like the
the fungi
um you know they have needs as well to
carry out their life cycle
and one of the needs that the tree
supplies is the is photosynthetic that's
the energy
um and the fungi when they're actually
colonizing a tree in order to
you know carry out their life cycle to
get the energy that they need
they signal back and forth between with
the tree the tree roots there's this
communication that goes on that's
biochemical is constant
um and what the fungi do is they message
the tree
to soften their root roots basically um
so that they can enter into this
partnership and
the tree uh signals the fungi to
branch and create you know we call what
we call apricorium where where they will
contact the root
cell and actually have a a chemical and
physical
impact on the root that then the fungus
can actually colonize the root system
and then between fungi as well fungi
different species of fungi they
they compete they collaborate they
message each other as well
um and with bacteria and the other
creatures in the soil there's all
there's a whole soil food web and they
all have these ways
of connecting and communicating with
each other and they enter into
sort of this food web where they have a
food web of feeding patterns and that
feeding pattern
is where you know larger uh
soil creatures will eat smaller and
smaller ones in that process of eating
down the food chain
they cycle nutrients because they
excrete out the excess nutrients
and that's what drives the the nitrogen
cycle for example in the phosphorus
cycle and all the sites these big
biogeochemical
cycles are actually based on or
dependent on these little tiny creatures
in the soil
right oh well that's amazing um and
after this question i'm going to invite
in
kevin kelly um but um you mentioned
in the talk that you you've designed a
100 year experiment which i
love and there's so few of such things
in the world but
i want to i'd love to get a little bit
of backstory on that like did were you
funded as a 100-year experiment or
you know do you have to kind of say it's
100-year experiment and then work on
funding of you know year over year or
yeah these are very difficult
longitudinal studies like this are very
difficult to
actually work in the world so i'd love
to hear the story behind it
yeah i mean working so working with
long-lived
large creatures means you have to have
long-lived large
experiments and you can embed in those
sort of short-term
experiments to try to understand the
mechanisms and try to predict into the
future what the long-term
trajectory might look like but you know
there's nothing like real data you can
have all the models in the world but you
need data to feed the models
so that they're accurate and so these
long-term large experiments are crucial
um i i became you know quite good at it
when i was a young scientist because i
was
i was studying you know forest dynamics
and young stands and we knew that we had
to have
large plots that we followed over long
periods of time and so there's a whole
infrastructure
associated with doing experiments like
that first you know finding the land to
do it on
and then finding collaborators who can
work at that scale
and then of course as you mentioned
finding funders who will
follow your work for a long time and
you know honestly they don't because um
funding is usually on a short scale
right i think the largest grant or the
longest grant i've ever had is five
years and so
yes it's a constant process of finding
always finding money to
to um to keep the project going
but you know it's it's like you know the
more you do
and the more scientists get engaged with
these long-term projects that are
interdisciplinary
it does attract funding as well so i've
found in this project that it's actually
gotten
you know it was we were lucky to get the
money in the first place but
every year we've been successful at
getting funding and i think that
i think that that success will continue
because the project is a success
you know we're we're publishing a lot of
articles we're finding out new things
that are directly relatable
to climate change you know i know that
the government is
directly wanting our data in real time
so they can adjust their
planting policies for example and so you
know
as as we've shown that it's useful in
groundbreaking really um it i i feel
hopeful that we'll continue to get
funding
you know through the years but i do i
think it will always be the case that
it's going to be
piecemeal year after year we have to
keep chasing the money but
you know it's worth it yeah i mean it's
it's
interesting i mean uh very obviously
with things like climate change we have
to be able to pay attention as a
civilization over decades if not in
centuries
um so um that's amazing that you're
embarking on
well yeah especially since i'll have to
say especially since we're short-term
thinkers
generally right where we at least you
know our economic
funding cycles are very short-term and
so it's it kind of goes against the
grain for long-term studies
um but it it you know you we need to do
it we have to do it
right well i think finding the
mechanisms the governing systems that
can work
in this case you know obviously there's
things like endowments that could kind
of work
you know and you know some kind of term
but um endowing every long-term
experiment might be
a bit difficult but anyway we're going
to invite in kevin uh one of our
founders here at longhound and the
senior maverick wire welcome kevin
thank you what a great talk it opens up
all kinds of visions in my mind
one of them that are surprised you
didn't mention that
may occur to other people was the vision
in avatar
of the fictional world yeah how well
that
corresponds to the picture you just
painted
um and i have so many questions
about the mycelium themselves you you
you mentioned
that um they seem to treat transport
resources that you know with the new
seedling coming in and tapping into and
benefiting from
the old elders
are the fungi actually transmitting
nutrients
along the mycelium for the benefit of
the other plants or is it their own
benefit and
the plants are sort of are they
symbiotic or what
what what that's a complicated picture
it's not just
bits that are communication but you're
saying they're actual
physical resources atomic material
moving along
is that right yeah so you know i know
that
um you know we i i often get the
question of who's in control here is it
the plants or the fungi
and the answer is both right they're
they're both
have agency in this and of course i'm a
forester and a tree person and so the
first thing
i did was i looked at the trees to see
you know if i adjust
their um resource how replete they are
and resources
or how rich they are or if they're fully
lighted or if they're in the shade and i
would change sort of like these
gradients between plants and i found
that when i did that it changed
how much of these resources were we're
moving and you're right it is
it is the resources it's the main things
that trees and plants need which
i and that's what i looked at where
water you know nutrients
nitrogen carbon those are the big ones
that they need and so
um and they are moving them around along
what we call source
sink gradients where you have a source
plant which is rich to a sink plant
which is poor
in those nutrients or those resources
the fungi themselves
you know they have needs too they they
um they need photosynthate or they won't
survive
because they don't have leaves they
don't have chlorophyll and so they get
that carbon that photosynthetic from the
trees and it's in their
best interest to be associated with
multiple plants and multiple trees
so that if one of them dies or a whole
species dies out of the forest
then they have other options they have
other trees that they're connected to
and so and so they are connectors right
and they do have
uh agency in how these resources are
moving around as well
and one of the ways to think about that
is um that
i mentioned that there are thousands and
thousands of species fungal species in
the world
in a single forest you can have a
hectare you can have about 100
fungal species and they have different
niches some of them are really
thick wide um almost like
very carbon rich fungi others are very
fine and
um you can barely you can't see them
with a naked eye
they do different things some of them
are really those thick ones are really
good at transporting water over long
distances
um the really fine ones are good at you
know exploring into new places
and getting getting resources from
hidden places and then moving them
through the network um and so yeah so
so just their different roles their
different niches means that they will
have
they have a role to play and what gets
moved around and how much gets moved
around
it's not just the the sore sink gradient
among the plants and the trees but it's
also
the species composition of the fungi
themselves
it was my understanding too that a lot
of these fungi actually go inside into
the trees themselves
up into the wood that it's not just in
the soil
but that they have fungi that kind of
are symbiotic basically
into the wood itself is that part of the
picture
yeah i i think it could be um so so
you can think of there's about four
groups big groups of fungi
there's um there's pathogens uh those
are
like parasites there's sacritos those
are what decay
materials the mycorrhizaes are the
beneficial fungi that form these
mutualisms
on the roots of the trees and then there
are endophytes and that's what you're
talking about
these are fungi that actually live in
the cells of the trees
that are not the roots but the actual
trunks of the trees are made maybe in
the
the larger root systems and we're just
starting to understand the role of those
endophytes
but some of them people think are a
symbiont you know
for example uh some of the the fungi and
even bacteria can live inside the cells
and they can do different things like
some some of the bacteria can
fix nitrogen so they're endophytic by
bacteria some of the fungi
you know they can have um defense
compounds that are important for the
tree and for the fungus itself and then
they benefit
from the carbohydrate provided by the
tree one
interesting example is in the u tree so
the u tree
pacific u texas brevifolia
has a whole arsenal of of defense
chemistry associated with it it produces
defense compounds
that help to fend off pathogens and
insects
and one of those defense compounds is
pat
is texol and taxol is actually was
discovered by the aboriginal people and
used as a medicine
and later rediscovered by the
pharmaceutical industry and is now
used for treating breast cancer and
other cancers and i was actually treated
with taxol
but some of those endophytes inside the
the the yew tree actually produce taxol
as well
so it's not just the tree the endophytes
the fungi that are living inside of
of the of the yew tree produces taxol so
it's kind of it's fascinating really
that you have
both of these organisms living together
producing these incredible compounds
that are for us as people are also
incredibly important
medicines so so the big picture you have
is that we have this
forest and trees as social beings
and we know from animals which are very
social that
their communication can be used for
cooperation but also for competition
so is there any kind of evidence that
maybe trees
as you were saying can use the the
fungal mycelium to
transmit messages of like don't come
here stay away from me
um it's not the kind of cooperative
helping each other but actually
using it as a means of competition as
well
yeah yeah actually they can um so
um i know that some of these fungal
networks have been shown to
transmit even herbicides or allelo
chemicals allelo chemicals are like
poisons
toxic chemicals that can actually you
know
poison another plant that it's connected
to um
and it and there's been a number of
papers written on that it's not from my
lab but other people um
and then but another thing that we have
looked at is um
is that you know we were working in the
arctic and
and one of my grad students julie deslip
was looking at bachelor nana which is
a shrub species that is actually
expanding across the arctic as the
as permafrost is melting and bachelor
nana
is a shrub it's been slowly replacing or
taking over
the tussock tundra and that's because
you know there's more nutrients
available as the permafrost melts
but also these bachelor nana are clonal
and they form mycorrhizal networks with
each other and
they transmit carbon from one parent
plant to a daughter plant to another
daughter plant and so
and this is facilitated we think the
expansion of bachelor nana
across the arctic and that's not
necessarily a good thing because
it accelerates the warming and the
melting of the permafrost
on the other hand it also means we've
got more photosynthetic capacity in the
arctic but
overall you know this is a response that
to
a fairly negative uh anthropogenic uh
climate change driven climate change
that that ultimately is uh
going to be difficult for us all to deal
with if if
people in the logging industry and
others
sure absorb your message about the
necessary social aspect of these forests
and how they could benefit even them in
the long term
are there new technologies that would
allow more
selective harvesting or are there ways
to do this other than just making it
more expensive
are you aware of ways in which
we can necessarily do this without
necessarily making wood cost
five times as much as it does right now
which is
very high because of uh shortages um so
so is there are other kind of solutions
to um working with this knowledge that
you have
you know i think that we've undervalued
our forest immensely
and we buy wood for like almost nothing
i know it seems like a lot because we're
not used to those prices
um but if we're really playing that the
true cost of clear-cutting our forest
wood would be far far more expensive and
so i think that
um you know we need to adjust our
economic expectations from the forest
and actually value it for
more than just two by fours we need to
value it for
the water the clean water that it
provides for the air it provides us i
mean how do you put a price on that
we need to put you know value it for the
carbon that can be stored
and already you know we're seeing
through carbon offsets and cap and trade
systems are
putting prices on carbon a move towards
that to valuing
ecosystems for the ability to store
carbon so it's a movement away from
these
very cheap products like two by fours or
toilet paper
that you know we've gotten used to
valuing force based on
you know these very simplistic notions
um and so yeah
we can make that change you know we need
to change the value of it
just like you know we need to make
conscious decisions we need to make
difficult decisions to get off fossil
fuels it's been
cheap for us to get that at fossil fuels
and we could kill ourselves easily by
just extracting it extracting it
but we need to make these difficult
decisions and say no it's too expensive
you know the externality costs of doing
that are way too high
you know and um and so sure it's
possible
of course it's possible and and i think
that the way
you know to change the value what we
need to do is just slow down
right we're cutting the force so fast
for what
right we're producing all these products
that we think that we need
um we could substitute products or we
can just
you know reuse products or be smarter
about our
you know the the products that are used
for building
houses or you know we can just be a lot
more conservative less consumptive
and then when we do log the forest take
our time
right so that when we leave the forest
that it's regenerative
not not pushing it to the point of
collapse
which is what we're doing now we're
pushing these systems to the point of
collapse
and i don't think anybody wants that for
their children or their grandchildren or
you know to leave behind collapsed
ecosystems so yeah we've got to change
how we
value you know all these life support
um you know what we call goods and
services in ecology now
um but all the life support system we
need to value it for what it is which is
allowing us to live on this planet okay
and my last question uh just very
briefly is taking off of um
zander's point about long-term thinking
and long-term
projects are you aware of of other
100-year surveys in
your field and are there
best practices that are being done
in terms of like say storing data that
you get this year to make sure that in
100 years someone can
get hold of it or other
other methods or processes that would
encourage people to
also attempt a long-term 100-year
project like you have
you know there are some very large
projects in the world
um uh that that need to be
protected and funded um the face
experiments are one ex
one set of experience free error carbon
exchange experiments these are
huge and they're they're well funded
where they're actually pumping co2 into
the atmosphere
in different ecosystems around the world
including forests and then looking at
the response to those
climatic changes that they're trying to
emulate um there's long-term
there's a long-term ecological research
experiments that
that have been funded by the usda forest
service
um and those experiments have been in
the ground for decades
in canada you know we we have we have
joined into some long-term experiments
there's the long-term
site productivity experiments where
they're looking at how to prepare
soils um over the long term but i'm not
actually aware of an experiment like
this one
you know where we've actually um started
it with a shoestring
and then built it to be you know it's
basically
covers a 900 kilometer climate gradient
and uh and so it is unique and it's
unique in that we've collaborated with
so many different partners who are
interested we've collaborated with
you know with big major forest companies
we've
collaborated with little tiny community
forests we've collaborated with first
nations
um and and research for us and so we
have
lots of interest and we've built this
thing from the ground up
and i think that um you know and we have
like you mentioned data
so you know we do store data in the
microsoft
with microsoft and we have long term
storage in the
ministry of forest it's it's it's
registered as a long-term experiment
and so but it it needs people to look
after it over time
and i know through my career which has
been a long career and i've had many
long-term experiments the data so easily
gets lost
even when you're doing the best that you
can you know suddenly that whole you
know first-year data is gone who knew
where it went
so it's really important to invest in
data storage and curation and then the
continual publication of the data
it is it's a it's a big investment but
it's well worth it because already
you know in the mother tree project even
in the five years that we've been doing
this
we have found out things that you know
can change completely change how forest
practices work
for the better well i wish you great
success in the next 95 years
thank you
indeed i mean i think what's you know i
a good experience thought experiment
always with these things is
imagine if we had this material and it
was already 95 years old instead of just
five years old i think it would be the
most valuable data we had on the planet
to learn about climate change
how it was going to affect us um if not
a thousand years at this data would just
be
amazing and i know um we also had a
speaker from uh
wayne clough when he was head of the
smithsonian i didn't realize this
the smithsonian is one of the longest uh
kind of uh
natural sites uh down in panama um
because of when the panama canal was
created but they've continued to do
um biology down there for over a hundred
years which is very cool
um i wanted to ask uh we had a great
question from
our youtube thread have you done it did
you
as a way of doing this did you or anyone
else do
soil isolated seedlings as a
as a control to learn about how if they
can't get to the mycelial network
how much worse or better their lives are
in this forest
yes for sure we've done quite a few
experiments like that and
um you know my graduate students over
the year years we've done it in various
forest types but we
they're very simple experiments you um
what we do is we create these chambers
um out of mesh of different sizes so the
mesh has got little tiny holes of
different
calipers different sizes that allow just
water to go through
or or maybe a fine mycelium or maybe
even a large mycelium
or a root to grow through or not nothing
can grow through
and we compare and we plant these bags
basically bags and fill them with soil
plant seedlings in them and they're
either connected to the old
trees if there's big enough pores in the
bags or they're disconnected if there's
no you know very tiny pores that only
water molecules
can grow through and then we compare how
those seedlings regenerate
and what we found is that when when
whenever a seedling can connect with an
old mother tree
that their survival goes up
significantly as does their growth rate
and their ability to to develop roots
and mycorrhizaes is all significantly
enhanced and and in stress for us which
i emphasize so much
in the talk this is really really
important
you know if you're only getting 10
survival without a network and then it
goes up to 40 which is roughly what
we're seeing
that's a big deal right that's a big
deal for the forest
so so yeah those experiments are not
hard to do but and they're but they're
elegant
and they've provided us with huge
amounts of information
nice and i think i mean that to me the
two biggest pieces of news that i got
out of this one is that the way trees
communicate and especially interspecies
is amazing but this other
thing that you mentioned that that
actually we as humans can help
facilitate
moving uh forests to um
to better climates um as climate change
is happening
to help facilitate the regrowth in um in
clear-cut areas
it's potentially further north maybe
than they would have been
is a really important piece of
information that we can actually help
this situation
um and i wanted to ask do you know are
there any institutions or others that
are
like taking on this this task of having
of helping to recruit uh into the
changing environment that we're creating
yeah we're already in canada
actively doing that and i would guess is
happening in the us as well
so the geneticists have been working
long and hard on you know
for understanding you know the genetic
uh or the genetic
makeup of seedlings and trees and and
their local environments
and they call those provenances so so
they match a provenance to
um a planting area and in the last
10 years i would say in canada they've
been encouraging
um people to plant at least 10 percent
of the species mix
with genotypes that are from warmer
provinces
so they migrate they're basically slowly
adding these migrants into the local
mixes of seedlings not
a hundred percent um and that's smart to
not do that it's got to be done slowly
and and you know moving genotypes like
that
because and the reason that we're doing
that is because you know climate
velocity
is about a thousand times faster than
the natural migration rates
and if the whole forest dies because the
you know because some insect or fire
because that was climate driven wipes
out the forest
um then we need to repopulate these and
we need to make sure they're resilient
and so that they've got the right
genotypes that can survive
and re-establish the forest um and we
need to make sure that we
bring these new migrants as i said in
the talk
into hospitable environments having old
trees left behind
and fires do leave old trees behind they
do
leave these legacies and we need to
emulate that in our own harvesting
practices so that when we
migrate seedlings into new climates
where they
you know eventually will have a foothold
that they're
they're in an environment that will
receive them and protect them and
and allow them to get through those very
vulnerable early years
thanks and i was encouraged to see in
some of the video in your talk that um
that young
uh i believe either undergraduates or
graduate students at least
are working in your lab and doing i know
we've talked to many
many of the kind of more extreme
explorers it's actually very difficult
for them to get the next generation to
go live out in these extreme
environments maybe your environments are
less extreme than some of these others
but how has how has it been to recruit
uh young scientists into this field are
they enjoying it doing it
they absolutely love it um i have a crew
of about 20 students out there right now
um and many many students on the apply
and i can't
employ everybody who wants to come i
have people from all over the world
saying can
i come and volunteer or you know even
you know seniors saying can i send you
five bucks to support the project and
um yeah so recruiting students is never
a problem and
it gives them you know they're part of
the solution then
and and then they you know talk to their
friends and they'll do
and they think of their own experiments
as well so
you know already a group of my students
are saying oh let's write a paper on
this one thing that i'm interested in
so you know we're training new
scientists for the future and we're
training advocates for the forest and
and once they get in those jobs they
don't want to leave them right because
they just
absolutely love it yeah it's really
it's really great it's really wonderful
well that's great and i just want to
close
um so i'd love to know if there's ways
that um
that we can help you or follow your work
what are you doing next what's
how can how can our audience help and or
what's what's next for you
well you know i think the most important
thing
is to um support the
drive to save our old forests and so
um that
and i think that you know and to tell
your friends that this is an important
thing
it's important for everybody is it
important for us now it's important for
our kids our
you know for generations to come this is
we're at a crisis point
and and we've pushed our ecosystems not
just you know our oceans our land our
forest
and i said to the point of collapse and
we're continuing to do that
we need to pull back save these old
forests so if you have an opportunity
you know to um to help save the forest
so
like maybe investing in carbon offsets
so that that we can
um you know substitute
making two by fours with keeping carbon
in the ground so you can do those things
you can push your governments to make
the right decision instead of always go
for the expedient
short-term jobs thing or you know and
it's and
and to be honest the and i say the jobs
thing it's not that jobs are not
important it's just that
forestry has become so mechanized that
there are less and less jobs even as we
cut more and more trees
and this is i to me is the wrong
direction mechanization and efficiency
is maybe good for the stock broker but
it's not good for
the ecosystems and then of course you
can invest
directly in projects like this uh
support them because they always need
funding right
the project you know i'd love to expand
this project down into mexico where
where douglas first southern limit but
we can't work just in canada
because that's only where our funding is
from and we only have limited funding
so you could you know invest in projects
like this that span
much bigger latitudinal gradients and
you know you can donate to projects like
this if you want
right well and hopefully even projects
that uh span great
temporal gradients so yes thank you for
working on this it's been amazing to
talk with you
uh and i can't wait to follow your work
brother thank you so much
thank you so much for having me
and i'd like to thank you our audience
and members and sponsors here at long
now this has been great and we look
forward to seeing you
at the next talk be well
[Music]